salvi youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito vorrei consigliarvi un canale e
il canale di jim 360 che come si capisce
dal nome tratta di argomenti riguardanti
l'xbox 360 fa unboxing e gameplay
classifiche video recensioni il tutto in
una maniera molto molto simpatica il
canale lo trovate come al solito non so
perché la gente indice non hai detto il
nome del canale no ma vi il canale state
tranquilli che non metto sempre nelle
informazioni del video il canale se non
sbaglio adesso che l'ha cambiato si
chiama logicamente jim e se vi iscrivete
ditegli che vi ho mandato io detto
questo iniziamo ed è di nuovo so bad
it's all good
i film che recensisco oggi e blog freak
un horror del 1972 diretto da brad grey
intero grinter 21 adesso baby food più
strani che io abbia mai visto
numero 5 45 minuti prima di raccontarvi
la trama vorrei dirvi più o meno come io
trovo i film da recensire io
semplicemente giro su siti che fanno
recensioni di film e leggo ogni tanto
recensioni di film veramente ori di
allora subito vado a cercare su wiki pd
o su altri siti la scheda di questo film
quindi la trama il cast eccetera leggo
la trama e se vi incuriosisce lo guardo
e così ho fatto per blog freak ho letto
la trama mi sono messo a ridere soltanto
leggendo la trama non ho detto questo
film lo devo guardare a tutti i costi il
problema è che la trama che ho
effettivamente eletto inizia soltanto
dopo 45 minuti di nulla assoluto per
tutta la futile parte iniziale non si
vede altro che il protagonista che va in
giro in moto e gente che sfuma acqua da
tutte le parti e durante la visione del
film e io mi dicevo si questo film è
brutto tra regia audio recitazione ma
poi finisce lì non c'è molto da
raccontare quindi la recensione verrebbe
un po inutile ma io non vi è ancora
raccontato la trama
numero 4 la trama
la trama di questo film non è niente di
che
il nostro protagonista che è un
motociclista è completamente a caso
incontra per strada una ragazza casa e
chiesa possiamo dire una di quelle per
benino molto simpatica e molto carina
che però ha una sorella che si fa le
canne dalla mattina alla sera
il nostro protagonista cade in questa
cerchia di amici che si spinella a tutto
andare e diventa uno spinello ma neanche
lui tramite amici di questi amici qui
trovo un lavoro come cavia umana
praticamente deve testare dei farmaci
sperimentali ma gli scienziati che gli
danno questi farmaci non sanno che lui
spinella e si trovi come un pazzo allora
questi farmaci a contatto con le droghe
hanno l'effetto collaterale di
trasformarlo in un serial killer omicida
non provateci neanche a trovare un
collegamento tra queste due cose
lasciate perdere
finché poi
grazie all'aiuto della preghiera e della
religione
lui torna ad essere un uomo normale fine
ve l'ho detto che non avevo una trama
così catastrofica
uno specchio mi sono dimenticato una
cosa fondamentale della trama quando i
farmaci a contatto con le droghe hanno
quell effetto collaterale di
trasformando in un serial killer si
trasforma in un pollo
in un pollo
quello non è un pollo è un imbecille con
la maschera da pollo gigantesca chi non
è neanche animata non ci hanno neanche
provato ad animare quella orribile no no
non togliete la che è orribile orribile
un pollo
[Applauso]
numero 3 regia ed audio come ho detto
prima larice l'audio di questo film
lo so lo so siete ancora scioccati dalle
immagini prima all'osso per le facce di
vedere poi adesso parliamo bene del film
come ho detto prima alla regia e l'audio
di questo film sono a dir poco
disastrosi nella regia possiamo vedere
la maggior parte delle volte delle
inquadrature
completamente sfocate c'è zum zum anno
su una persona che sta parlando lei
tutto completamente sfocate non si vede
assolutamente nulla nell'audio invece
che credo sia la parte peggiore di tutto
il film possiamo sentire dei dialoghi di
cui almeno io non ho capito neanche
mezza parola the web e palladio
presenterò in una nota
ci rinuncia voi vi chiederete ma se non
hai capito neanche un dialogo come
cavolo è fatto a capirla trama
fatti non l'ho capita su dovuta dalla
leggere
numero due le vittime come vi ho detto
prima c'è un uomo polo che uccide delle
persone
lo so che è difficile ma ve lo ripeto un
po più lentamente per permettere al
nostro cervello di elaborare nuovo pollo
che uccide delle persone ok la prima
vittima dell'uomo pollo e una ragazza
che sta per entrare in macchina e lui
tipo ninja diciamo vuole in modo
silenzioso catturarla
che la scena dovrebbe essere drammatica
ma guardate questa splendida immagine di
ir la rarissima bellezza io lo so che
lui vuole lentamente e silenziosamente
andare dalla ragazza per non farsi
sentire da lei mai una testa di pollo
gigante questa scena non può essere
drammatiche anche se vi punti una
pistola alla tempia
comunque lui silenziosamente riesce ad
afferrare la ragazza è senza tapparle la
bocca lei non urla neanche un gridolino
estetico
ma ora soltanto quando è fuori
dall'inquadratura il pon ora sta
uccidendo
mi sembra ovvio ed infatti questa cosa è
chiamata pessima regia
le successive due ragazze le catture
leucci ne è un modo abbastanza crudele
le lega a testa in giù le taglia la gola
e ne lascia morire dissanguate come dei
maiali un pollo che uccide le persone
come maiali
poi c'è la scena di lotta fra il pollo
ed un bestione e indovinate è fatto
malissimo
poi c'è una scena che mi ha stupito
molto perché era fatta bene molto bene
è una scena violenta quindi io non so se
posso farvela vedere io vi avverto
adesso vi faccio vedere proprio qualche
immaginetta non è tutta questa violenza
però so che c'è qualcuno che ama e che
magari non piace vedere scene un po
sanguinolente magari anche fatte benino
quindi io vi avverto adesso ma anzi
facciamo che ve la racconto e poi voi
decidete se guardarla no praticamente
lui cattura una persona la porta in un
magazzino dove ci sono segni a motore
eccetera lomelo mette su un tavolo e con
una sega nell'italia una gamba e lo
lascia morire dissanguato ma se lo devi
uccidere tagliargli la gola a dire no va
bene un importo questa scena mi ripeto
mi ha stupito perché è fatta veramente
veramente bene vi faccio vedere le
immagini
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
a
[Applauso]
ha visto di solito nei film quando ad
una persona viene tagliata a una gamba
si vede che è finta si vede che la gamba
ce la vera ce l'ha nascosta da qualche
altra parte poi mettere una protesi di
plastica di silicone dipende mi metto il
sangue finto eccetera qui invece si vede
proprio che lui a tutte e due le gambe
una è tagliata sapete perché perché a
quell attuare veramente manca una gamba
quindi hanno sfruttato questo problema
per fare una scena di una gamba mutilata
e decennale questo il problema però a
risana una scena prima quando l'attore
in questione è ancora con tutte e due le
gambe corre fa sì come l'attuale in
questione ha una gamba sola e l'altra è
una protesi perché per davvero non ce
l'ha guardate come corre si vede
chiaramente che sta zoppicando e non
riuscire prima non aveva motivo di
zoppicare basta zoppicando perché
poveretto lui ha una protesi la il
regista gli ha detto devi correre in
questa scena e ora va come faccio a
correre se c'è una protesi e infatti
zoppica
numero 1 il finale ma un film del genere
come potrebbe mai finire secondo voi lui
uccide tutti e rimane per tutta la vita
all'unico uomo pollo al mondo
no alla fine rapisce lo scienziato
trovano akureyri diventa normale no ma è
ovvio che in realtà tutto il film è
stato una grandissima allucinazione
ovviamente è questo risponde alla
domanda come far diventare inutile
un'ora e un quarto di film per un po un
dispiacere sa perché in realtà lui non è
mai diventato un pollo
credo ma non finisce qui perché il
protagonista capisce dopo questa
grandissima allucinazione che le uniche
risposte alla droga sono la religione è
dio ma è ovvio perché uno quando pensa
ad un film con dio e la religione si
immagina droga sesso spinelli ed un
pollo gigante
comunque questo film alla fin fine non
so se consigliarvelo le scene in cui lui
un pollo gigante quella parco e la parte
li diciamo la seconda parte dei film
ancora ancora è guardabile ma i primi 45
minuti sono l'inutilità fatta a
pellicola perché non succede nulla ci
sono tanti dialoghi di cui non si
capisce nulla per colpa dell'audio c'è
molta gente che si drone si spinella e
massa noi non c'è nient'altro quindi se
volete vedere un uomo con una
stupidissima maschera da pollo
guardatevi la seconda meta ma fatelo da
soli perché altrimenti rischierete di
perdere amici grazie questo film ne
approfitto per ringraziarli tutti gli
scritti di tutti i commenti tutti i
complimenti che mi fate e vi ricordo
anche che io ho un secondo canale un
forum e facebook eccetera il link sono
tutti nelle informazioni del video di
tutti i video
così se volete dare un'occhiata potete
farlo